Before moving on from this question of
evaluation, I want to take another look
at the connections between
the various subproblems.
This network is called a butterfly
network because the connections over
here on the left look
a little like a butterfly.
Also note that there is
a unique shortest path
between all nodes on the right and
those on the left.
Another thing to note is that
this sequence of evens and
odds on the subscripts of these
polynomials can be translated to binary
with e's being translated to 0s,
and o's being translated to 1s.
And these numbers, then,
tell us which coefficient of
the original polynomial to return here.
And this makes sense, because when
we chose the even coefficients,
we were choosing those that
had 0 in the lowest order bit.
And when we chose the odd
coefficients here,
we were choosing those with
1 in the lowest order bit.
It will also be instructive
to write out the power
applied to omega here
on the right-hand side.
It turns out that these numbers on
the left act as instructions for
any path to this node from the right.
And these numbers on the right
act as instructions for
how to get there from
any node on the left.
Let's go right to left first.
Reading this bit sequence on the right,
we find that 0 tells
us to go the even route first, that is,
the higher of these paths everywhere.
Then the 1 tells us to go to
the lower route, towards the odds.
And then the last 1, again, tells us
to go the lower route towards the odds.
And indeed,
that provides instructions for
going from all of these nodes
over here to this one over here.
The reverse is analogous.
We think about the least significant bit
first, so to get to 6, going from here
to here, we go to the omega that has
the lower of the possible powers.
And then in the next step, we go
towards the one that has the higher
of the possible powers of
omega in all these cases.
And the same thing in the last step.
Again, going towards
the higher power of omega,
which is the downward of these paths.
This network is well worth some study.
It serves as an important example in
graph theory, and the topology here
has been used on some massively parallel
computers for their memory architecture.